I turn the volume up in the back okay so
it's a better now okay okay yes so it's
about sort of making these technologies
a little bit easier to to use and
develop and we've heard from some people
already in this conference about their
experiences sort of as non-experts and
differential privacy sort of coming into
the community and trying to use these
technologies and I think some of the
themes that came up in those talks were
to motivate some of this work but just
to sort of set the stage I want to
consider a kind of a hypothetical
analyst so imagine there's this analyst
who's collected data from say a census
and their goal is to produce say a to
weigh marginal between the race of a
child in a household and the race of the
householder okay and they want to do
this under differential privacy so they
they say okay well I need to go find a
differentially private algorithm for
this so they they look through the
literature and they're sort of scanning
through the forty thousand plus I guess
twelve papers and you know they come
across one paper that compares two
algorithms and they say okay well
algorithm a it looks pretty promising
maybe I'll try that for my for my
application but then as they sort of
make their way through the literature a
little bit further they come across
another paper and it sort of appears as
though the picture is just the opposite
and it may be algorithm B as a better
choice okay and while this example is
hypothetical these these figures are
real so this is actually the results
from two different papers so they're not
sure which of these techniques to use or
whether there's even a third technique
that's even better but nevertheless they
sort of set out and they say well I'll
just go ahead and try out both of these
on my data okay
unfortunately the source code for these
algorithms wasn't available so they they
had to implement it themselves okay so
they set out to do that and the first
thing they need to do is they need to
think about the the sensitivity because
that's ends up being a sort of an input
to these algorithms so the sensitivity
of the the queries or the statistics you
want to calculate so the analyst sort of
looks this table and they say well I
imagine you know if I were to you know
add or remove like actually this should
be a smaller number because that's on
that child so imagine that's a 11 so
they think about well if I were to add
or remove a child from this database
well that could
affect sort of one row in this table and
therefore that would affect you know the
count of one of the cells in this
marginal and it could sort of go up or
down by one so that kind of reasoning is
not sort of that's that's somewhat
reasonable but it turns out to be the
wrong answer for the value of
sensitivity for this particular query
nevertheless they proceeded and they
turn to implementation concerns so they
they have to come up with some sort of
source of laplace noise so they sort of
look around and they find some Python
package that allows them to sample the
plus variables from some pseudo-random
number generator and so there they're
kind of working on their to their
deployment everything's looking good and
they're ready to go but then they have a
friend who you know knows that
differential privacy expert they say oh
just before you deploy watch out for
floating-point precision attacks okay
and so they're like you know what and
they point to this paper and it's very
complicated so they sort of throw up
their hands and they say I'm just gonna
use self-suppression okay so okay so
hopefully they don't do that but so this
example sort of illustrates some of the
challenges that they experience in
trying to get differential privacy to
kind of work in their application so
they sort of look through the literature
they see conflicting empirical results
there's kind of lack of tools out there
and and reference implementations for
sort of canonical algorithms like
Laplace mechanism and then there's risk
of sort of subtle bugs as they go right
so and I think there's bugs at several
levels so there's bugs in the analysis
so doing the sensitivity calculation and
making sure that you are reasoning in
the correct way about worst case
scenarios but then also challenges in
terms of implementation right so you
know I want to be sort of secure against
sort of side-channel attacks and things
like that
so today I want to tell you about some
of my work that tries to make this sort
of process easier so I want to talk a
little bit about DP bench which is a
benchmark study doing an empirical
evaluation of the accuracy of different
technical difference a private
algorithms I want to tell you about ekta
Lowe which is a framework for kind of
doing the kinds of differentially
private computation I just described and
then lastly I want to talk about ongoing
work which is on private sequel and this
is about sort of an interface that
allows you to express say a workload of
sequel queries that could be complex
over multi relational data and it and it
gives you back differentially private
answers and so that you know this is
sort of tore in the spirit of actually
trying to eliminate the effort involved
for that analyst and they can just
simply you know use this system instead
and it will take care of all those
concerns okay and the kind of allocation
of time is not proportional to these
three things so I'll probably just spend
a little bit of time very little bit of
time on DP bench a little bit more in
Ekta low but hopefully have some time at
the end for a private sequel but feel
free to sort of stop and ask questions
as we go okay so in terms of DP bench so
I think you know we try we set out to
kind of empirically evaluate the
accuracy of various differential private
algorithms and it turns out to be quite
complicated because there's many factors
that affect the performance and I won't
sort of go through all of them I'll just
highlight you know one which is that
these algorithms a lot of them have data
dependent performance because they
either sort of adapt to the data and so
or they introduce some other kind of
statistical bias when they're doing
their differentially private
computations of the day and this is not
an exhaustive list by any means but just
to some of the examples where some kind
of bias is introduced so we developed DP
bench there's a companion website DP
comp and actually an earlier speaker
mentioned this I just wanted to sort of
share sort of one finding which is that
we were able to explain that sort of
apparent discrepancy and the previously
that I mentioned before about the two
algorithm sort of appearing to perform
very differently and basically the idea
there is that performance really depends
on sort of the signal strength in your
data so and that signal strength is
governed by the epsilon that you're
using the number of records in the
database as well as other factors and so
if you're in a sort of low signal regime
say really small epsilon or small data
some type
nice work comparatively much better than
others but as you move to sort of a high
signal high strength high signal
strength regime other other techniques
tend to dominate and so that's why we so
those two papers are really just looking
at two very different regimes another
thing that ash when touched on the other
day is you know we created a bunch of
these visualizations and there were
algorithms had sort of interesting
artifacts that you could see visually
you know sort of rectangular regions
showing up in in these sort of two
dimensional spaces that kind of puzzled
people when they were looking at them
and if you don't know how the algorithm
works it's sort of hard to explain why
those artifacts are there and I know
talking to people with the Harvard
privacy tools project that sort of
similar issues arose there as well but
really I actually just want to say that
I think sounds doing this kind of
empirical evaluation is really important
and this is sort of more of a call to to
the community that I think we should be
thinking hard about about ways to do
this and ways to incentivize people in
our community to do this and so you know
certainly benchmarks is one way and in
other research communities really you
know take their benchmarks very
seriously in it and it really drives
some of the research innovation some of
the contests you know what Christine
talked about the other day with with
what they're doing I think is a great
way of sort of getting people involved
and there's other things like conference
reviewing processes where they impose
reproducibility requirements that at
least gets at this to some extent
so yes that's that's really all I wanted
to say about the kind of DP bench work I
want to move on and talk about about
Ekta low so so this is a kind of a
framework for doing differentially
private computation I've already sort of
touched on some of the challenges of
doing this kind of deployment and I
would say sort of successful deployments
have always required a team of experts
you need sort of experts in differential
privacy in the room and and it's for a
variety of reasons right there's there's
limited resources available there are
you know I want to say there are really
good works like pink that that do some
things really well right so what pink
does really well is it ensures kind of
safe privacy safe computation you can
it'll kind of automatically calculate
the sensitivity for you but it doesn't
provide as much guidance on other
aspects of the problem and as I get
through act alone I think that should
become more clean
I think in particular it's very
difficult for non-experts
to sort of contribute to these
deployment efforts because you know
there's just so many ways in which you
can kind of you know make make mistakes
right so this sort of privacy it's very
difficult to get it right even when you
want to get highly accurate answers you
know sometimes need to leverage
sophisticated algorithms and maybe do
things that are somewhat
counterintuitive you know thinking
really critically about the measurements
that you take and then typically in a
deployment you know the context really
matters so that sort of particulars of
the view of the data that you're working
with and variants that may apply
structural zeros all those sort of
things come into play so it's unlikely
we'll just have sort of one black box
algorithm we can run but rather we need
a sort of toolkit that allows us to to
set up a differentially private
computation specific to our data okay so
that's sort of the goal for Ekta Louis
is to simplify and accelerate this
process it's a sort of operator based
framework and I'll go into that in the
more detail in just a second but the
idea is these operators and codes some
of the best practices in the literature
for different aspects of the
differentially private workflow and I
put in the Sun because I mean we can't
keep up with this field there's so many
great innovations that we have some some
great ideas imbedded in X lo but
obviously there's sort of more work to
do to continue to incorporate new ideas
as they come along but the idea is that
you a differentially private computation
is expressed as what we call a plan in
act Lo and you can just think of this as
it's effectively a sequence of calls to
these these operators in otherwise
arbitrary code okay so I'll actually
give you a little example well I'm not
going to go I'll sort of walk you
through this slowly but this is sort of
a a pseudocode version of the top-down
algorithm that Dan Kuiper mentioned on
Monday that the that's being used at the
census for the 2020 decennial it's just
to be clear that is that algorithm is
not implemented in Ekta lo I think it
could be in principle and really what I
want to do is sort of illustrate sort of
the the kind of potential benefits of
thinking in this kind of operator
framework by taking that algorithm okay
so the way xlo works right is you have
this plan okay and it's executed in sort
of a client environment but there's this
API that connects to the database which
is kind of wrapped in this protected
kernel and sort of the only ways you can
access the data is through this API okay
and that's and and in that way we can
sort of control exactly how we're how
we're interacting with the data so I'll
walk through this code so so the first
thing you do is write instantiate some
protected data source let's say it's a
person a table of people we'll loop over
different geographic levels okay so for
each geographic level you know so state
county blocked track we will select sort
of those geographic regions and then the
first thing we do is a transformation
operator or we take that original data
set and we sort of split it up into into
smaller data sets for each region okay
we loop over those those smaller data
sets and for each one we invoke this
vectorize operator which takes the data
from a sort of micro data form into well
you can think of as like a histogram
overall person types okay so these both
of these operators here are examples of
transformations they're not actually
releasing anything about the data but
simply just manipulating it to prepare
it for later computation the next step
is an operation of measurement selection
and so top-down uses HD mmm and that
actually is now an operator in Ekta low
it takes in a workload of queries that
you want to answer those are represented
in a matrix form applied over this
vector X but the only thing that HD mmm
does is it simply outputs a measurement
matrix M okay so it's actually not
touching the private data but it's just
coming up with a good set of
measurements to answer the queries in
this workload the next step is to
actually carry out those measurements
and so we invoke the Laplace mechanism
but it's embedded in an operator where
it takes in this matrix does the
appropriate sensitivity calculation
which may actually depend on earlier
transformations that were done on the
data and it gives you back noisy noisy
answers and then the last thing is is
various sorts of inference and
post-processing okay so we want to
at the very least make so come up with
an X hat which is an estimate of the of
the original vector that's consistent
but as Dan talked about at length
there's all sorts of other additional
post-processing that's that's being done
in this application to incorporate
invariance and to ultimately generate
micro data and that's that's not
necessarily captured here okay but one
thing I want to sort of point out is if
we think about it in this operator
framework there's sort of different
types of operators here okay so the read
operators which were transformations
right those those are those these are
this is client code but these require
making a call to that protected kernel
to actually transform the data okay and
so something has to happen in that
trusted environment but this part
doesn't need to be differentially
private we just simply need to make sure
that the appropriate transformation has
done and that if it has any impact on
later sort of sensitivity calculations
that we record that information
somewhere the only thing that needs to
be differentially private is the actual
measurement itself right because that's
where data is sort of leaving that
protected kernel and coming across the
line and then there's all sorts of the
green code which is happening on the
client side which has no impact on
privacy okay
so certainly that includes post
processing stuff that happens sort of
after the differentially private
computation but I want to also observe
that there's a bunch of things that
actually happened before the private
computation and in fact yes oh sorry no
this imagine that goes up to there yeah
yes yes yeah everything yeah I moved
there everything got shifted down in my
last minute editing yeah sorry about
that
yes so this points to the Laplace nice
okay but this client-side operation has
no impact on privacy yet you know it's
it actually is a very significant
component of the computation like this
HTM M algorithm you know Ryan jerome
student ryan worked very hard and has
developed it's just some really nice
tools there and it's it's fairly
complicated but yet it's all you know
happening before the the private
computation okay yeah so so that's the
top yes
maybe I'm sure you're aware of this but
this is the kind of example a bit that
like I think Dave sensor was talking a
bit during this week where is true that
the Laplace for instance the gold part
is if au is the only one that touched
the day that is really where we had the
problem with the data but in some sense
if you go if you look at the information
flow that you have from the data this is
not the only place where the data plays
wrong like when you do partition so it's
not exactly I mean I understand that
this is what you are getting to because
the red part you mean that it should run
in a trusted environment because it has
access today but I don't understand
exactly which sense you differentiate
the control flow the information flow
between the red I mean even in pink
these are differentiate because one is a
transform but there is no real
difference in there more flow
information from my perspective okay I
think I hear you're saying I think there
is a nice way of decoupling and it's and
it happens in pink and also happens in
Ekta low and in fact we we definitely
leveraged a of sands sort of proof of
privacy for for a pink in thinking about
this system I think the separation is
that Minoo you do want to these do need
to run in the trusted environment you
want to vet that they are doing the
right thing right so you could imagine
you know a transformation that you know
an adversary could say well if Alice's
and the data and has this property I'm
going to do this transformation but
otherwise I'll do this one but but
really you know as long as the
transformation sort of is implemented
correctly and you can imagine an on
privacy expert designing a test suite
and sort of evaluating that or writing a
proof that yes this filter takes in a
predicate and applies it correctly they
don't you don't need to know
differential privacy expertise
there is a dependence though and so
these these transformations can affect
how much noise you need to add here but
I think there's there's frameworks for
handling that and you can think about
basically just the stability of these
the sensitivity of these operations in
terms of the the you know symmetric
difference that changes that they make
in the data and then and then add the
appropriate yes I think that's a better
yeah yes somewhat related so the results
of the read operations do they also are
they all like stay behind that API yes
well what is a client-side so there's a
few ways of thinking about it one is you
could think of this vectorize operation
as actually performing a computation
eagerly on the inside the protected
kernel and so now there's like a new
there's an X vector that's in the
protective kernel okay I should have
clarified this is just a handle this
actually isn't you can't inspect this X
right if you tried to like index into it
you'd get an exception right it's just
sort of a handle the the other thing is
actually the kernel doesn't have to do
anything right they could simply just
record and this is the way sort of spark
works as a data analysis platform it's
all lazy computation it's just saying
okay I understand you want to perform
these transformations and if you ever
actually ask me for the data I will
carry them out and so this call here
could actually invoke a whole sort of
all of the operations nita to prepare
the data then do the measurement and
then the Y actually does sort of this is
where you this is actually materialized
on the client-side yeah yes probably
need to see to say that the
the programmer has access to the
complete schema to make sense yes yes
yes this is the danger of doing a
high-level overview with a bunch of
experts I did skip a lot of details and
you and you cut them off yeah okay okay
so so just sort of concretely Knechtel
oh that we have organized the operators
into these different classes I've sort
of all ER I think already Illustrated
what these classes do
concretely here some of the operators
we've actually added to it since I
created this slide you know and I'll
just maybe observe things like some of
the query selection operators actually
are orange because they do actually
consume privacy budget right so
something like what's used in mmm is to
in a differentially private way ask
which query is sort of the worst
approximated one given my current
estimate of the data and you need to
consume some privacy method for that and
leveraging the work by Dave sands and my
amitabh Adi we have a theorem that says
you know as long as you vet the kind of
red and orange operators then any plan
you write is differentially private so
we took X lo and this there's a lot
going on on this slide out but we took
actually wrote a bunch of rewrote a
bunch of algorithms as xlo plans and I
have these kind of cryptic planned
signatures here you don't really need to
digest them all but I want to highlight
some benefits so one is you see actually
the same operator showing up lots of
places right so L M is the Laplace
mechanism a particular implementation of
the Laplace mechanism that takes in a
sort of measurement matrix and it shows
up in a lot of different plans and so if
we implement that one Operator well and
and vet it carefully then it can be
applied lots of places and if we sort of
make algorithmic innovations in the
operator lots of different algorithms
would inherit that the other thing is a
bunch of algorithms actually have very
similar plans traps signatures except
maybe one Operator has been changed and
I think when you look at these papers I
think it's maybe for experts in the room
it's obvious how these algorithms are
similar or different but I think it
wasn't until we sort of wrote them down
as ekdal Oh plans that we really saw
just how similar they were
and there's sort of that's an iterative
loop a repeated process yes we don't
have the exponential mechanism as a as a
base operator yeah there's then there
are other operators sparse vector
technique that is not in here but
certainly these are things that we could
yeah this is noisy max behind the scenes
yeah okay
I so mother benefits you know in terms
of checking privacy we really only need
to well modulo Marcos earlier comments
you know we need to vet certain
operators but not all of these operators
because a bunch of them you can see our
sort of green and and it doesn't really
matter what's happening there
another thing is kind of with this
framework new algorithms are easy to
sort of think up and so we we kind of
played around with things like mmm and
came up with different variants of mmm
just swapping out an operator here or
there and we could actually see
significant performance differences by
doing that so it's kind of easy to
iteratively develop new algorithms so I
just so that was pretty much all I want
to say about xlo but I wanted to sort of
make a comment about you know because I
know Salil is talking later about kind
of open source tools for differential
privacy and I think our work on ekta
Louis got us thinking about sort of you
know architectures for sort of
differentially private systems and and
what maybe that might look like and I
think there's a lot of benefit of
thinking about sort of the separate
concerns right this idea in software
design of separation of concerns and we
can see several I mean there's the
transformations measurement selection
and measurement post-processing and then
even in post-processing there's lots of
different sort of kinds of
post-processing either sort of getting
consistent answers generating synthetic
data some of the work that York
presented yesterday about sort of
statistical inference on top of the
noisy data and and in general in
software there's obviously benefit of
doing this kind of modular design
but in particular in the privacy context
I think there's some some specific
benefits one is I think it does reduce
the scope of sort of privacy
verification if we're trying to say
really be sure that this satisfies
differential privacy you know there
there's specific areas where we can
focus and we can be very explicit about
the dependencies between these operators
the other thing is I think it opens up
the opportunity for contributions from a
wider community because I think for
depending on which task you're taking on
the kind of relevant expertise changes a
lot right so if you're in
post-processing it's a tote you don't
actually don't even know anything about
privacy it's really a statistical
problem transformations there's actually
a lot of work in the database community
on sort of covenants and information
flow and in other communities that is
separate from privacy and I think you
don't necessarily need to be an expert
in privacy to just reason about how one
tuple in an input could sort of
propagate to changes and changes later
on and of course the great work by the
some of the folks who presented on kind
of automating proofs of privacy right
could be very valuable
you know inserting certain aspects
certain components of this what's your
vision development using
designers of these algorithms and what
could be difficult of all of domain
experts like with respect to this
development domain experts in terms of
the sort of statistical agencies well I
think I mean I think so I think all I
mean you can imagine sort of this entire
workflow and thinking about sort of the
important aspects of the problem I think
that you know Chris talked about sort of
imputation right as being an important
thing in the Community Survey I would
sort of view that as an example of a
transformation it's a kind of a
complicated transformation but I mean it
I guess in terms of I mean in terms of
sort of who can contribute I mean we
made act a low open source we're
continuing to develop on it we'd be
happy to sort of see other people using
it and developing it and adding new
operators or even adding sort of
automated proofs of privacy for
different operators so we'd welcome
contributions
okay how am i doing on time here about
ten minutes plus question okay okay let
me i guess i'll tell you a little bit
about the sort of highlights of private
sequel yeah so okay so the idea here is
that it's a it's a query engine that
takes in sequel queries a workload of
sequel queries and sort of computes
differentially private answers
automatically so it is potentially sort
of just a useful tool to have and that's
one motivation but i wanted to highlight
sort of two other motivations for the
work so one is that we're seeing in
practice like very complicated queries
over multi relational data and i'll use
some census examples to illustrate this
right so since this collects static
computes variety of statistics that can
be used for lots of applications one of
the products is summary file one which
contains both queries about kind of
individuals and statistics about
individuals but also statistics about
households and people living in the
households when you try to formalize
these as sequel queries i won't expect
you to digest all of this but these
these queries get quite complicated this
one is actually just a linear query on
the household sort of measuring counting
up the number of households at satisfy
certain properties there are other more
complicated queries where this is
counting the number of people but it's
counting them in terms of a property of
their household right so if you think
about it there's a little bit of a
subtle dependency between the people
you're counting and other members of
that same household and this complicates
the kind of sensitivity analysis and
there's even more exotic things where
and this comes up in other applications
but here where it's sort of a count of
count so we're for every household size
computing the number of households
having that size yes exotic if we were
demographers we would say essential
okay okay so that's one motivation as
these complex queries I think the other
thing is this idea of privacy not
necessarily different traversing not
just leaving a one-size-fit-all
definition but actually needing sort of
a variety of different ways of
instantiating it so I should mention
this before but I just want to mention
that sort of certain data products you
may want to protect individuals or the
number of people but in other data
products you may want to actually
protect entire households and this sort
of shows up in lots of applications you
know the census I just mentioned in
social networks people have looked at
you know edge privacy versus node
privacy in event streams you know you
can think about hiding an individual
event versus a window of time versus an
entire users trajectory and the goal of
private sequel is to automatically
generate answers to sequel queries like
the ones I show you given a fixed
privacy budget and then to allow this
kind of privacy at multiple resolutions
let's see I'll just say okay so so
really quickly you can think about sort
of two approaches to this there's been
some work on answering sequel queries
the Flex work by Don song's group and
others as deployed at uber you know one
limitation is that this is a sort of
query at a time approach and so the
epsilon accumulate and you get this
potentially unbounded privacy loss a
specific de flex
in particular the semantics actually are
a little bit unclear in terms of it
hides any row in the database but
depending on the application you know
this may not actually align another
approach is to generate synthetic
synthetic data various forms and there's
lots of great work on this but I would
say it's limited to data that's in the
form of a single table okay so there
isn't support for multi relational data
and in particular if you were to just
sort of generate synthetic versions of
each table on its own if you try to join
or link across these tables you will end
up getting very high err
so so given this background you know how
do we how do we think about this in
private sequel we have a solution for
this defining privacy of multiple
resolutions I'll just maybe briefly
mention it so we specify a privacy
policy you pick one table as your
primary private object but then related
then you define you think about
neighboring databases as adding or
removing a row from that table but also
actually all of the tables that kind of
transitively refer to that table and so
if we were to take say this this data
here let's look at household privacy the
household is the primary private
relation but neighboring databases occur
by adding or removing not only a row in
the household but actually all of the
members of that household as well okay
and while this is you know a kind of a
very reasonable sort of definition the
point is to automate this and allow us
to choose the policy that we want and
have the system kind of automatically do
the appropriate sense diva sensitivity
isolation okay so I'll just walk through
the sort of overview of how private
sequel works so the key is the first
step is this idea of view selection and
this is one of the main ideas so
hopefully I can get through this so the
idea so what is a view so view is is a
single table that is the result of
essentially a complex query over the
original input tables okay in a
particular week so we want to select
views so that every query that the
analyst wants to answer can be computed
on just one view and in particular that
computation is linear over the view so
it's a you can think of it as basically
a counting query over where you specify
a predicate it's a little bit more
general now that's the basic idea so you
could imagine here could be a view right
where you have each row corresponds to a
person but notice that we also are
encoding the household size right which
is actually aggregating information
about multiple people and recording it
and attaching it with each person's
record the next thing we do is we take
these views and we generate
differentially private synopses and so
we can leverage all the great work on
sort of generating taking a table and
generating a differentially private
version of it these could be this could
be synthetic data this could be
histograms
or tabulations whatever is appropriate
for the application we have to allocate
budget across these things I won't get
into that and then we need to ultimately
answer a query so you now imagine that
an analyst writes a complicated sequel
over sequel query over this data we have
to rewrite it in terms of these snopp
C's this is a well studied problem in
the database literature of sort of query
answering overviews and so we can
leverage the work there but this can
have this we can the analyst can do this
sort of all day long because it's just
post-processing on these these produced
views one of the most interesting things
is the sensitivity calculator which is
thinking about and this is sort of
already come up a fair bit and the in
the talk already thinking about how a
change to the original source data could
propagate and be a change to to these
views okay and so this is a very
complicated problem I want to just
highlight sort of a few aspects of it so
so doing this kind of sensitivity
evaluation is hard and Marco actually
has a nice paper sort of proving some
some hardness results there we leverage
some work in in pankin and flex to have
this kind of sensitive sensitive a
calculator that produces an upper bound
on the sensitivity we have some kind of
new ideas there that actually have a
very significant impact on the accuracy
but even if we sort of have this
calculator unfortunately the sensitivity
in some cases can be very high or even
unbounded so if you think about this
example right where I've encoded this
household size the worst case databases
everybody lives in the same household if
I were to remove one person from the
data every row in this table would then
change right so how do we get around
that I mean this is this is not a
uncommon thing but we have this idea of
using truncation where we sort of try to
estimate the the general frequency of
say household size and then and then cut
things off and impose these kind of
truncation operators into the viewed
about the sensitivity there's definitely
other techniques out there but that
seems to work well for our application
the last thing which I think is really
interesting is thinking about this
supporting multiple privacy
levels so household person and so on
what we do is we have a view so what we
want to do is have this thing not have
to be rewritten every time we change the
policy we'd like this to be sort of
general but then we want to be able to
change the policy and have everything
work out and so what we do is we have
this view rewriting step where we
actually make the dependency on the kind
of primary private table explicit so I'm
skipping over the details but you could
imagine you could have a query that's
just about people about the person table
but if the household is the primary
private object then actually we need to
think about those changes and we can
actually add sort of joins or semi
joints with the household table into the
query plan and then that actually makes
that dependents explicit we rewrite the
views and we can support a cyclic
dependencies cyclic dependencies so
imagine like a table that encodes a
family tree so so-and-so is the parent
of someone else that's more complicated
I'll skip over the empirical evaluation
we compare with you know computing
techniques okay you know we compared
with flex and this line here is actually
just reporting zero so we want to be
below that that line you know it kind of
depends on the size of the query answer
and things like that but we can you know
in that and the sort of improvement
comes from several things that sort of
tighter sensitivity calculation doing
truncation instead of smoothing so
smooth sensitivity as an alternative
truncation at least in the applications
we looked at seems to actually give us
much better performance and then we have
this kind of better composition because
we're using these views and then we can
actually leverage parallel composition
across queries to the same view
so just to wrap up with private sequel
so I think this idea of you selection
and schnapps this generation is an
interesting approach
and gets us away from some of the thorny
or issues of just answering one query at
a time we can support privacy resolution
at multiple levels or privacy at
multiple levels and we can sort of do it
in an automated way which i think is
really nice but there's lots of hard
problems here in terms of bounding the
sensitivity there's lots of and just in
terms of that there's lots of open
there's lots of open questions with all
of this with this project but in
particular with the kind of sensitivity
calculations there's some really nice
work on sort of more sophisticated
mechanisms that that we could
potentially use here I think there's
some really interesting questions around
this bias-variance tradeoff so if I do
truncation I'm injecting some bias but
it's essentially reduces the amount of
noise I have to add but what what is the
right sort of threshold to pick how do I
pick that threshold in a differentially
private way and so on and then of course
Emma and this has shown up in other
conversations and talks you know if I am
injecting this bias how do i quantify
that error and let the end-users
actually understand the impact of that
okay so just to wrap up so you know
attacked a little bit benchmarks and and
their potential value to the community
ekta low is sort of a tool for
simplifying and accelerating this kind
of algorithm development and then the
work on private sequel you know we're
excited about that and it you know it
opens up this possibility of a kind of
declarative inference interface so a
user doesn't need to know about privacy
they just sort of expressed the queries
that they want to answer and the system
can can do it for them and support kind
of queries over complex multi relational
data okay so that's that's all I want to
say thank you
[Applause]
yeah sorry about from e-liquids
background so I was wondering when you
comin detect a low whisper me to use and
if that helped you of you know who the
premonition is here to facilitate the
norm especially so we chose Python maybe
for more practical reasons you know I
think just to be clear you know we have
these sort of these operators that that
actually do the sort of differentially a
private computation you know it's sort
of for ekdal oh we can kind of treat
those as black boxes and sort of we set
aside the problem of actually carefully
vetting that code to make sure it's
differentially private is sort of a
separate problem so but you could
imagine you know in a sort of the
production system that maybe you'd want
to replace that with a language that's
more amenable to out analysis and where
you'd actually write sort of an
automated proof but since so many people
are already actively working in that
space we decided to leave that problem
to them so we yeah so with the view
rewriting yeah so we so for instance say
with the house of like a query about
people but the private object is the
household we would estimate so we use
some differential private privacy lost
budget to estimate sort of household
sizes and then and we can do this in a
general way where we sort of look over
the base relations and look at sort of
the frequency we look at we look at
attributes that occur in the queries and
then we look at the frequency of those
attribute values in the base tables on
the data in a differentially private way
so now we get a distribution for sort of
how frequently each value occurs and
then we can choose a sort of cutoff
point right so so in this case like
concretely like large households would
just get sort of dropped from the data
and then and then we can actually
rewrite that that truncation operator
explicitly into the view and so now our
sensitivity calculator can reason about
that and say well I know that that
because of this truncation operator now
I can bound the sensitivity and smooth
sensitivity I think I think one problem
there is that there there is the sort of
long tail and so the smooth sensitivity
is going to sort of look at them X right
and then come up with a smooth upper
bound on it and so so not only is it
sort of starting with a larger value but
then actually because you're doing this
kind of recursive calculation on the
view that starting with a larger value
sort of compounds because later
operations could sort of double or we
dropped them I think in part there
there's some work by Dave sands that
looks at there's some subtleties with
sort of how to drop them partially so
because if you just sort of take the if
you have a deterministic algorithm that
just sort of takes the top ones then
they're subtle things where if you you
know yes so we just dropped them but I
think you could potentially do you know
smarter things and that's something that
so this is the question it's a comment
and kind of a suggestion
I've known members of this team for more
than a decade and they've been working
on hard problems like this for at least
that long
a lot of the recent progress to be frank
has been motivated by having a pretty
well-defined use case which is the
massive amount of publication that the
Census Bureau does from the decennial
census this team phrase that was the
first one to systematically go through
the publications and try to express them
in a standardized database language so
that it opens up the tools that you
could use from that languages it's
really shed a lot of light on what we do
that that can be addressed by
specialties that are largely absent from
the Census Bureau when the demographers
at the Census Bureau think about this
problem they have a table writing
language that they think about it in
that table writing language is the
progression of generations of software
designed to operate on hierarchical
databases that were household service
some people may be many decades ago
tried to restate all that in terms of
relational databases and basically the
user community pushed back then went
back to the format that they were used
to using now we have a really good use
case or not just different privacy books
for rethinking the way that the entire
work load is conceptualized what what
does this it's really enormous progress
all below the the surface so it doesn't
necessarily produce something usable but
it came from being motivated by a really
specific use case I think that's right
yeah absolutely yeah
more more rich benchmarks we have the
more of these problems with surface and
they will be solving to the problems
that are very very very I'm guessing
from the citations you put at the end
but you haven't used the phrase like
restricted sensitivity when when talking
about this truncation operation can it
be understood yeah I thinks I mean I
think it's yes well I think I think it's
maybe like a simple version of that I
think that that is a really interesting
direction to think about in terms of
sort of coming up with more
sophisticated how do you let other other
citation that is a mechanism we are
figuring out ways in which you can use
this where you can do something with
multiple unit theories on it how do you
do that based accessibility well the
recursive mechanism is ellipse it's
expected
[Applause]